[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 29 décembre
voici les titres chaque année 4,5
millions de personnes sont victimes d'un
accident domestique la période des fêtes
de fin d'année ne connaît pas de trêve
en la matière coupures lors de
l'ouverture des huîtres brûlures les
risques sont nombreux tous les bons
conseils à suivre avec le centre
hospitalier privé m'ont gardé à
aubergenville aider les jeunes des
quartiers à saint céré grâce à la
pratique de disciplines jusqu alors
inaccessible c'est le credo de
l'association ferait qu à chanteloup les
vignes elle fait découvrir notamment le
golf rencontre dans cette édition et
puis pour la première fois de son
histoire le football-club de versailles
à l'occasion d'atteindre les huitièmes
de finale de la coupe de france ce
dimanche les yvelinois disputer les
seizièmes de finale et réception de la
roche vendée football nous prendrons le
coup à quatre jours de cette rencontre
vous vous apprêtez peut-être à
réveillonner pour la saint sylvestre ce
vendredi et en ces fêtes de fin d'année
attention aux accidents domestiques y
sont légions pendant cette période alors
quels sont les bons conseils à adopter
pour éviter de se rendre aux urgences le
soir du nouvel an mathilde francou s'est
rendu au centre d'urgence main à
l'hôpital mont garder à aubergenville
des guirlandes lumineuses qui prennent
feu un bouchon de champagne qui
explosent des boules de noël qui se
brise chaque année le service d'urgence
mains de l'hôpital privé du mont garder
à aubergenville enregistre un pic de
fréquentation à la fin de l'année on a
beaucoup d'urgences on a entre
12 à 15 urgences par jour
avec essentiellement de l'accident
domestique pendant la période des fêtes
des couteaux à huîtres et des infections
aussi sur des plaies par antoine 8 ans
l'équipe est composée de six chirurgien
spécialiste de la main à l'épaule qui
assure en moyenne 23 mille interventions
chirurgicales par an et le 31 janvier
les accidents les plus courants sont
causés par des pétards ou des tirs de
mortiers pour éviter de se blesser il
faut faire attention il faut mettre des
gants quand on jardine il faut éviter la
manipulation de pétards artisanaux et de
mortiers pour faire des feux d'artifice
dans la rue le 31 au soir si vous êtes
victime d'un accident au niveau de la
main le premier réflexe est d'appeler le
18 le numéro d'urgence des pompiers puis
d'envelopper sa main dans un linge
propre mais surtout prudents avec le
couteau à huîtres
dans l'actualité la crise sanitaire du
coc vie 19 depuis la prise de parole de
jean castex premier ministre et du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
lundi quelques précisions et mesures
complémentaires ont été présentés d'eux
à retenir notamment les discothèques
déjà fermé depuis début décembre vont
rester fermés pour trois semaines
supplémentaires jusqu'au 24 janvier
minimum annonce ce mercredi du ministre
délégué chargé du tourisme et des pme
jean baptiste lemoyne sont concernés
dans les yvelines plusieurs
établissements notamment à louveciennes
autre annonce les partiels se feront
bien en présentiel dans les universités
en janvier a confirmé la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
environ dix neuf mille étudiants sont
inscrits à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines le taux d'incidence
un explose chez les jeunes de 20 à 29
ans ils étaient 2000 566 cas pour 100000
habitants au 24 décembre
rencontre à présent dans ce journal cela
fait trois ans et demi que l'association
fera etc permet à des enfants de
découvrir des disciplines jusqu alors
inaccessibles en mêlant sport et
éducation l'association veut aider des
jeunes en difficulté à s'insérer et
daoud et mohamed notamment deux jeunes
qui fréquentent le club de golf de
villennes-sur-seine un reportage signé
senin charles
green caddie club ces mots n'ont plus de
secrets pour daoud et mohamed une fois
par semaine depuis plus de trois ans ces
deux garçons de 16 ans se rendent au
club de golf de villennes sur seine pour
apprendre la discipline j'adore golfe
surtout le practice et
toute la semaine j'y pense quand j'en
fais encore j'en fais pas comme tu tape
la balle au practice ça détend comme
celle proche de là où tu crois tu vois
la balle partir loin après même le jeu
sur le parcours ça me plaît
ah oui elle est belle celle là
130 cent vingt 120 les sports qui sont
connus sur le quartier on va pas se
mentir c'est plus voilà le
foot la boxe tout au début c'était très
très difficile de le faire accepter sur
le quartier parce qu'il n'était pas
qu'une inconnue c'est plus pour les pour
les gens aisés pour les gens qui
s'enlise une chance qui leur a été donné
par l'association freq qui allie sport
et aide à la scolarité elle est
accompagnée par la fondation goisnard ou
ce qui permet aux enfants défavorisés de
pouvoir accéder à des activités
extrascolaires son coach et après moi vu
qu'on ait beaucoup chez moi on n'aurait
pas à ma mère elle aurait pu payer faire
un sport pour moi cher et d'espoir pour
les autres os mais comment avait fait
pas du golfe comme ça et monde y est ce
un sport cher maugis mais j'ai eu la
chance
d'avoir à mina du coup que grâce à cette
occasion j'ai pu en faire mais sans eux
je ne serais pas là je tiens à les en
remercier venir aussi jouer au golf 6
aussi
l'accompagnement à ce sport
être respectueux travail et la rigueur
côté ou pas ouais bah je la sens
parce que corps je la sens pas la balle
c'est un qui sait trop bien on ne voit
avec ce nuage elle maintenant les
golfeurs qu'on a c'est de ne pas leur
fermer les portes il faut qu'ils
essayent ce sport et qui soit ouverte
aux c'est vrai que sans la formation les
parents ne pourront pas payer la
totalité de ce sport avec comme exemple
les célèbres bobby jones tiger woods ou
encore qu'albert tchaï daoud et mohamed
ne compte pas s'arrêter là j'avais
d'être pro et si possible au dessus
c'est d'aller le plus loin possible
peut-être devenir ont un jour c'est une
fierté d'avoir deux
d'avoir mettre des jeunes qui sont là
depuis trois ans et demi dans le golfe
et il les accompagne et si une fierté
porno une quinzaine d'enfants sont aidés
par l'association sur la discipline du
golfe l'association ferait qu envisage
d'organiser plus de court par la suite
pour que les enfants puissent passer
leurs drapeaux équivalent du flocon pour
le ski et participer à des compétitions
dans les yvelines
du sport encore pour refermer ce journal
avec l'événement sportif du week-end la
coupe de france qui revient pour les 16e
de finale de la compétition ne reste
plus que 32 équipes en lice et parmi
elles le football-club de versailles 78
notre fier représentant yvelinois qui
reçoit dimanche à 13h45 au stade mont
boron la roche vendée football club de
nationale 3 c'est la première fois
depuis 1948 que le club versaillais
atteint les 16e de finale de la
compétition va en parler avec melvin
vieira qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir
vous êtes joueur du fc versailles milieu
de terrain dans ce club que vous avez
rejoint est d'ailleurs cette saison dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous à j moins 4
de cette affiche
on est on est détendu on est tranquille
on
travaille tous les jours on a passé noël
au chaud maintenant la reprise on a eu
lieu lundi faut se remettre dedans mais
on change pas nos habitudes on
on travaille toujours autant à
l'entraînement avec du sérieux de la
rigueur est ce un match de foot on le
prend comme tous les autres matches
qu'on a pris depuis le début de la
saison vous avez été en pause pendant
quelques jours il ya eu à noël
maintenant vous avez repris c'est un
match forcément dans une période
particulière il ya aussi ce nouvel an
qui va arriver comment ça se prépare
vous le dites on ne change pas ses
habitudes c'est du travail du travail et
entraînement oui c'est ça
on arrive le matin on passe du bon temps
ensemble on rigole et dès qu'on met les
pieds sur le cabba ont
mal est sérieux on mêle sérieux avant
tout et et le travail après il ya le 31
qui arrive c'est sûr que pour nous c'est
différent parce qu'on veut pas le fêter
être avec eux nos proches etc mais on a
fait un choix c'est ce et les
inconvénients de notre sport mais on la
choisit donc on va pas se plaindre de
passer
nous y aura pas d'excès dans la nuit du
31 au premier vous confirmez non peut
pas se permettre de faire ça surtout a
surtout à ce niveau là de la compétition
c'est votre première personnellement 16e
de finale de la compétition en coupe de
france non j'en ai déjà fait deux alors
justement est-ce que vous en parlez à
vos coéquipiers qui sont peut-être plus
jeunes essaient de partager aussi cette
expérience leur dire ce que ce que ça
signifie aussi d'être à ce stade de la
compétition
on en a déjà parlé entre nous de nos
différents parcours il ya pas mal de
temps de ça mais à l'heure actuelle non
n'en parle pas après c'est sûr que le
jour j le jour j les anciens se décrire
un peu plus d'expérience dans ce domaine
là et à ce niveau là c'est sûr qu'ils
prendront la parole et ils auront
quelques mots pour le reste du groupe
mais pour le moment comme je vous dis
voilà on travaille on rigole
on n'est pas encore dans le match en lui
même pas de la pression ou le joue pas
avant d'être jouée on va traverser on va
le présenter c'est la roche vendée
football un club qui est l'actuel
deuxième de nationale 3 pays de la loi
qui est invaincu encore cette saison en
championnat et l'équipe est rentrée en
lice un de culte troisième tour de la
compétition elle a éliminé plusieurs
équipes de son niveau c'est à dire la
nationale 3 mais aussi une équipe qui
évolue en nationale 2 une division au
dessus d'elle c'est chateaubriand au 7e
tour sur le score de 2 buts à 0 et
châteaubriant c'est une équipe que vous
connaissez très bien puisqu'elles
évoluent aussi dans votre poule en
nationale 2 vous l'avez rencontré en
septembre il ya eu le score de 2 buts
partout à domicile au match aller elle
occupe la troisième position juste
derrière vous en championnat ça veut
dire on le voit bien que la hiérarchie
ça ne veut pas dire grand-chose en de
france même si vous évoluez une division
au dessus de cette équipe vendéenne
non je pense pas surtout à ce stade de
la compétition je pense que tout le
monde est sur un même pied d'égalité
après on parle pas des grosses écuries
qui peut avoir comme le psg et l'om
autres soldats mais nous à notre niveau
des claques une division d'écart war 2
grand max je pense que avec l'envi
l'engouement la détermination pour
certains c'est le plus beau moment de
notre vie dans le foot la de france ô
folies d'hier c'est notre seul moyen à
nous les clubs amateurs de les joueurs
amateurs de pouvoir jouer contre des
professionnels non il va parler nous
être médiatisé et c'est notre seule -
nokia là où il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de divisions d'écart c'est un match
de foot et avec l'atmosphère qu'il peut
ya voir l'engouement et comme je vous
dis l'excitation le fait de vouloir
briller se faire voir être médiatisé ça
met tout le monde sur le même pied
d'égalité
d'ailleurs son surnom c'est la coupe de
tous les possibles ça montre aussi qu'il
ya des parcours
possibles et improbable anciens qui
peuvent se réaliser sur cette coupe de
france vous parliez du du psg et de
marseille vous n'étiez pas trop déçu
lors du tirage au sort de ne pas avoir
justement de ne pas hériter d'un club de
ligue 1 pour ces seizièmes
non après moi personnellement j'ai déjà
battu venus il ya donc je vois et je
sais ce que ça fait après oui on veut
jouer c'est que le veut ces clubs là
mais quand penser comme vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure le club c'est son record
les seizièmes de finale c'est son record
et le fait d'avoir un adversaire on va
dire plus à notre portée
plus à notre portée sur le papier au
conditionnel comme on peut dire ça nous
laisse une chance à nous de pouvoir
vraiment écrire l'histoire et les seuls
peut-être à être arrivé à ce niveau là
avant que peut-être d'autres personnes
nous dépasse mais pour écrire une ligne
du club oui c'est dans un coin de votre
tête on l'a compris et on l'a compris à
ce que en atteignant les huitièmes de
finale ce serait la première fois pour
le club dans son histoire je lisais une
seule participation en 16e de finale
c'était en 1948 on va revenir sur votre
parcours vous êtes entré au 4ème tour de
la compétition vous allez piocher un
gros francilien on peut le dire un dès
le début puisque c'était brétigny une
équipe de nationale 3 francilienne que
vous avez battu sur le score de 3 buts à
0 puis a eu cachant département sa lune
neuilly sur marne bry sur marne
régionale 2 lumbres un club du pas de
calais une r1 que vous avez gagné on va
dire un peu à l'arraché vous perdiez de
buzeins à dix minutes de la fin et vous
avez gagné finalement 3 buts à 2 il ya
eu poissy également une équipe qui est
dans votre poule en nationale 2 avec une
équipe illinois ce qu'on connaît très
bien sarre union en 32e sur le score de
1-0 est ce qu'il ya un match où ça a été
plus difficile justement d'obtenir cette
qualification est ce que par exemple le
match contre lumbres était le match le
plus difficile peut-être dans cette
compétition
lumbres ça a été difficile
par un terrain pas facile de
caumont comme je vous l ai dit tout à
l'heure quand on joue des airs aoun ou
r2 c'est comme si nous on était la ligue
1 en fait pour nous et parce que on est
une équipe de nationale 2 après neuilly
ça a été compliqué aussi sa part été un
match ça va être un match facile
3 si ça a été dur aussi même sa réunion
tous les matchs ont été difficiles après
la difficulté du match aller différentes
mais on n'est jamais passé par la grande
porte on a toujours dû respecter notre
adversaire allait au bout de nous-mêmes
et et faire le maximum sur le terrain en
donnant de sa personne en appel le match
facile donc je vais dire que malgré les
divisions qui peuvent nous séparer avec
les équipes rona plafond affronter on a
eu un parcours où on a dû mettre le bleu
de chauffe et charles nécessaire passera
pas été facile et c'est un match qui se
déroulera au stade mont boron alors lors
du dernier tour vous étiez allé en
alsace il une poignée de supporters qui
vous avez suivi la dette devant le
public forcément ça ça donne aussi de
motivation supplémentaire on peut
l'imaginer
oui après c'est le deuxième match qu'on
joue à la maison on avait joué poissy
aussi et comme je vous l ai dit tout à
l'heure il ya un huitième de finale de
coupe de france qui est en jeu ça veut
dire qu'il reste que ces équipes
on est à domicile
on a égalé le record du club on peut
rentrer dans l'histoire du club donc
pouvoir le faire à domicile et partagée
derrière avec les gens qui nous
soutiennent qu'ils qui nous aide tous
les jours bat vois ça serait ça sera un
plaisir une dernière question melville
le club a de grandes ambitions pour les
années à venir avec eux de nouveaux
investisseurs qui sont arrivés à la tête
du club un ces groupes city en
championnat de nationale 2 vous êtes
actuels deuxièmes à un point de la
réserve de lorient qui ne peut pas
monter un puisque c'est une réserve d'un
club professionnel la coupe de france ça
peut vous aider pour le championnat où
finalement on est sur deux compétitions
complètement différente et ce cas il
peut y avoir un lien est ce que ça peut
vous propulser aussi en championnat
ou non ça peut nous aider le fait
d'enchaîner deux de passer des tours ça
donne de la confiance quand on gagne
après oui ces deux compétitions
complètement différente c'est pas le
même enjeu on va dire qu'en championnat
si on fait un faux pas on peut se
rattraper le week end après alors qu'un
coupon peut pas et jusqu'ici c'était
bien d'être dans les deux compétitions
comme ça on n'avait pas de trous dans
dans notre calendrier et tous les
week-ends on pouvait jouer et garder le
lait après maintenant si on se qualifie
je sais pas si on va devoir jouer en
semaine 6 et les week-ends et c'est ça
c'est c'est encore différent mais
je pense que si on se qualifie ça ne
dérangera pas de jouer en semaine et on
ira trop chercher des ressources
chercher des ressources à l'intérieur de
nous-mêmes simplement monté sept manches
avec toutes les yvelines qui seront
derrière vous un versailles la roche
vendée football 16e de finale de la
coupe de france est ce dimanche coup
d'envoi à 13h45 au stade mont boron
l'entrée sera de 10 euros le billet est
acheté est directement sur place et la
rencontre peut se suivre également à
distance sur eurosport player bonne
chance mais devine vieira et merci
d'avoir est avec vous avec nous
le rappelle milieu de terrain dans ce
club du fc versailles 78
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de nous avoir suivis retour de votre
journal demain pour une nouvelle édition
de demain jeudi belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]